hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to until dawn now
these choices that I have made actually
are reflected right here Sam looked at
Chris's incoming message therefore Chris
was offended by Sam's indiscretion and
then Chris was offended
therefore Chris criticized Sam for being
nosy with that lovely face over there
and then with this one Chris chose not
to shoot the squirrel nature remained in
balance so there's nothing else to that
that's just what that is and that adds
something to do with like the guidance
token totem that I had before that's
queued me milady
shall I take these up to yonder room hmm
I hope I get a nice tip after this
getting chills we're almost there
no I'm getting kind of creeped out oh
yeah uh-huh
weird seeing everyone else here again
yeah Mike yeah he's intelligent driven
and persuaded somehow I doubt all of
those things Mike seems like a yukata
shop you really really didn't see your
faces right dude I almost clocked you
just now nice one Michael you're a jerk
oh yeah hey guys we're all friends here
right no need for violence just a little
harmless fun welp in the woods
spooky come on let's get in the spirit
of thing maybe dating married seriously
what's wrong with you yeah what's wrong
with you try to lighten the mood M don't
be like that
like what the way you're being you
always get like this
hey back off Mike you better back off
Michael you gotta step off Emily and I
are together now and that's just the way
it is yeah hey I tell you again
yeah do we understand each other well I
thought maybe we can we past all this
buds but yeah I'm gonna make a butt of
this it's totally cool down the road oh
so it's your and by myself over
here oh cool yeah these beasts bees have
a piece have a little bit of peace peace
that's right I'm all alpha yeah what hey
could you take these the rest of the way
the bags yeah all the bags
um why I need to go find Sam okay sorry
I just I really need to go find her I
totally forgot I needed to talk to her
before we get all the way up there
that's really can't wait we're almost
there
it's important not please
I'm not leaving you alone you're not
leaving my sidearm I really don't think
you should head back down the trail by
yourself seriously it's cold out it's
getting dark yeah you're gonna protect
me from it being dark out yes up here
and come with you
nobody's gonna steal it not are you
kidding me you can't leave me alone for
five minutes you really think that
little of me yeah what I meant wait
Anson to me why do you have to question
everything I said shoot him I'm just
trying to be helpful
oh well then you can help get everything
up to the lodge as quickly as you can
see you up there after I go find yeah by
choice Teddy Bannerman but he damaged
our relationship after I was being all
alpha well there we go
more choices does just what did you
protect you good big bad baby
hello weird glowing eye girl Ashley has
a crush on Chris academic inquisitive
forthright
don't they have a crush on each other
why don't they just date then it's so
pretty
it's so pretty oh okay what was that I
heard that over on the left hold on no
nobody's getting a little friendly
oh I need to check the expiration date
on their big breakup oh no no no oh no
no no oh no no no no oh oh sorry their
sorrow that asked I didn't mean the
scary
what did mean to scare you sort of scary
but not like for real scary gosh oh my
god hey well man I'm I'm really sorry
ash Dan it's okay it's fine what are you
looking at see anything just without the
seconds uh uh encouraged yeah take a
look you need to see this go ahead knock
yourself out
uh-huh uni doesn't see this
Hey shine not dogs yeah Emily what the
hell man hey listen nothing nothing you
think is it ever just nothing with him
ever I don't know I damn it you're
telling me fugly importantly
I'm happy with my choices I'm happy with
all of my choices
hey honesty is the best policy that's
why xinhua me coming down with her
getting her Mack on with the guy Mike
her his name is read a book be
educational read a book
unless it's Twilight then burn it burn
it good boy hey what'swhat's the jump
scares you did not just do that
oh yeah concealed we've got you
surrounded
the hell am I to retaliate with Joyce to
ask Wow babble girl hey around her to
the strapping baby I come to take me
into custody
grab snowball no run to the bench hide
yeah right triangle thing rap crap crap
is right here oh this is time for a
little snowy hanky-panky well uh I can't
Oh bang
oh how to shoot boink Oh miss me bird
bird those in a premonition I remember
this
I remember the Lord okay Mike okay but
stop it seriously just stop okay
am I supposed to get the bird something
doing nothing is different
you can't hide for me Michael oh no damn
Jess what you did I know I know I know
poor Freddy poor little Tweety birdy
stone cold Jess I didn't do it on
purpose
I did it I did not a purpose well why
did he kill it it was a snowball oh my
god Michael gotcha
John John City so did I go down ah I
don't think so hey my my
so are we calling it my favorite then
your worthy opponent Miss Jessica the
snowball point here's a dance vaguely
dirty milady uh grab snowball flip put
irradiated stuff I don't wanna kiss that
douche oh ho oh okay you're really gonna
get it what am I gonna get well I can
think of it least one thing yeah well
you'll have to wait until later I don't
want I really don't want it did you hear
that
oh my god holy crap that was really
close
nothing was gonna kill us yeah mmm
Wow if you hadn't pulled us out of the
way toast let's get out of here
well maybe not I mean you do have thick
jacket it is only ice I mean yeah it did
fall from quite a bit of like quite a
bit high but I don't know if it would
have the power to impale both of you
from that velocity I mean yes it's it's
in a pointy shape but you have thick
protective winter clothing I mean maybe
you would hurt one of you really badly
but I mean like hi oh god not you and
how are we worse now oh I believe that
in our last session you were not
completely honest I was all never that
honest but what you yourself experiences
don't this time we're going to try to
understand the root of your anxiety yay
now pick up that book I don't want
pictures you will see a set of pictures
and symbols I want you to identify which
image in each set makes you the most
anxious okay cool great all righty then
whoa women women worried me hmm I don't
know that guy looks like he's being
angsty but that girl looks like she
could kill me yeah uh-oh
plain or well neither of them really
scare me I guess I have more of a chance
to die in a plane crash
Shruti was revealing my personality to
all of you guys
I figure Heights I thought oh god
drowning uh-huh the ocean in general
just blood filled with death constant
unrelenting death Thanks they scare me
what a rad scare me they're cute they're
adorable am i lying now oh okay you're
not even carrying knife or
knives I think knives are more scary up
close and personal
sure connector still snakes a little bit
right now you don't have anything to say
about this nothing nothing oh that's
care go ah I clowns all right that clown
just look silly but goddamn what is that
oh this is like picking out what scares
it's gonna give me okay did I startle
you
so sorry you're doing very well oh sorry
oh so sorry am i doing well
don't be nervous don't be nervous okay
try to you okay speed up the more you
rely on your instincts the more honest
your asses will be and the more out
lightning you will find this experience
I don't find it enlightening at all
maybe they do okay let's go uh still
snake spiders are cute
go go go go speed speed speed still gar
speed speed speed speed speed
come on yo you got startled me again
bring on douche nozzle oh god that's so
unsettling I don't like it
you're still Gor fear dogs that's a wolf
not a dog sit sit still Garf so garceau
door don't startle me dude god this is
very interesting you didn't know thank
you for answering so diligent diligently
snakes scarecrows yep and awful
the Sun combination sounds like a good
Friday night
oh well I'm afraid once again we're out
of time oh yeah the time oh oh thank you
I'm trying to remember who that actor is
because it's like it's it's so weird cuz
he's right in the uncanny valley of
everything like his face it's very
detailed knee animations are very well
done I don't I don't need this I don't I
was just playing I was just playing
what's going on whereas mr. Cohen was
precious I was just playing
first off I gotta say I am super excited
to welcome all my pals back to the
annual Blackwood winter getaway I really
want to spend some quality time with
each and every one of you and just share
some moments that we'll never forget
for for the sake of my sister's okay go
find Sam
sure you do so I got moved to the
back and next to Josh that's how we met
boom butterfly effect
I didn't need that I was literally just
bailius mountain gets bigger every time
I climb it oh yeah that feels the same
to me hi Josh how's it going with your
one eye open more than the other complex
thoughtful and loving it's kind of
unsettling for some reason okay come on
you grew up here probably feels like
it's shrinking I guess that's true yeah
we need to install some cell towers up
here I'm getting withdrawals already you
got a spare million lying around I'll
fix you right up
footage say that I think I left my other
jacket get up here okay yeah Oh more or
less but there's so good to see you
uh-huh talk with him
he's grumpy he's a grumpy one bish he's
a grumpy groupie one p whoo he's grumpy
because his girlfriend's all back in on
my key move and then my key move almost
got impaled and not in a good way you
get things moving up here or what yeah
man yeah man you doing all right
Hey you doing all right don't all right
I know must be really tough about your
setup I just meant that I know what you
meant
yeah seriously I'm over it and I just
want us to have a good time you know
like we always stood hey freakin thing
sighs what else maybe there's another
way in there are a million ways in there
just all locked it's gonna be like a
window around the corner we can get like
get open or something
wait a second are you saying we should
break in to my own house technically
breaking in if you own the place
hmm if I don't report you um
lead the way cut ha ha ha ha what's
Cochise mean would you call me hi would
you call me
I appreciate your staring at the back of
my neck Sakura confident nice being back
so how are you doing
oh good but a little cold think I could
use some time curled up by the fire she
sounds familiar to us she sounds really
familiar yeah sounds nice with you and
me all right okay
catch you later ash it's gonna circle
back for a little bit stare your face
okay all right Oh God wait no uh uh I
thought of a died never mind okay uh
maybe uh uh so what did the beaver say
to the penis okay I'm out of here thank
you very much okay bye come along Josh
hurry hey Josh can we have this auger
situation I swear please he'll be okay
hey you back off
she's like a sleeper hit kind of gal you
know I just want to rip that parker
right off of her and make some snow
angels right
hey wait cut it out man my god hey cut
it out man
yeah I mean you're not gonna bang her
maybe Michael take up the cake what will
you back off good very bad girls check
missing it there's some blood flowing
down there yeah listen dude look around
you look at these beautiful mountains do
you see any parents I mean can you
imagine a more perfect ripe scenario
just dripping with erotic possibilities
ham and Ashley alone at last
hate all the groundwork you've been a
perfect gentleman now you come in for
the kill
you're right but could you put it in a
more wrong way hunter bro no fear no
mercy I mean she won't even know what
hit I think she'll have an idea of what
better Wow now the skis so so creepy
that come to bed more creepy yeah buddy
you sounded like you had a plan I favor
Cochise or else you got four lovely
ladies who are gonna be freezing their
buns off and last time I checked that's
not a good way to get laid Thanks
good one good one this is quality
quality stuff here quality Xanax can I
have that oh it's gone Oh someone tooks
did it hmm
well well we got ourselves a thinker
nice one ah a myself or something
that's right use all your lower back
twin twist and push at the same time
really dig in with you the base of your
spine take your knees completely out of
the equation
mmm okay oh my back
see that's the exercise you do after you
just did some heavy lifting should pay
more attention at climbing class
you mean gym yeah you know what they
climb up the rope whoa tugging yeah I
don't think so you're gonna make here
use this
oh thanks dude you're gonna make me go
into this place off oh thank you thank
you friend solid I have a phone
I just got an awesome idea yeah totally
what is it okay so I'm pretty sure that
I've got some deodorant in one of the
bathrooms you could use that with the
lighter
I don't follow how does it as a stick of
deodorant gonna help spray on it too can
oh yeah now I gotcha flamethrower just
like we did with glory dudes yep ones we
melted just point to spray can in the
lighter and pipe I've frozen wha oh okay
you got this I'm gonna go sort something
out you up for hunting around in the
dark for a little bit no but I'll do it
Godspeed flanks John wine okay this is
nerve wrecking and weird why did he
leave me alone what if there were
murderers about oh hello hello head he
do to you hello
Oh totem in the house sure perfectly
explained to bull bull
okay so maybe I shouldn't do the burning
of the alive maybe a flame throws a bad
idea me boy who the hell are you huh who
the hell do you think I am
alright so there gotta be something else
I can do that frozen lock besides that
okay just skips go hello ah axe janitor
convicted for arson swears revenge on
movie moguls family okey-dokey then
that's probably pretty important for
something brother
don't know why yet but I'm gonna find
out somehow someway pretty pretty much
someway somehow okay
I think that's everything oh god I do
not like this huh what was that painting
shut up Oh
skull who did that the hell was it yeah
that's what I'm asking
okay hello how are you doing up okay
so we're in my nose who's whispering
who's breathing whoa no oh no no no whoa
no no no no hello hello fine ladies oh
hi Chris very funny Oh how'd you know as
me shouldn't you be like getting the
lock open or something all right
Arnie okay beer or beer root beer RB I
just got to make sure I don't burn
someone alive cuz that would be a bad
thing there's gotta be another way to do
it
shut up who keeps breaking in my
house
hello you a glint igloo
No mirdon oh god what is that oh it's so
creepy in the corner over there yeah
because I didn't mention it before I
really really really really really do
not like mannequins it's like the same
feeling that I get when I uh for people
that have Tripta phobia just to get an
idea of how I feel when I look at
mannequins it's the same exact feeling
my skin just crawls it looks wrong my
brain is just telling me no no what is
that I saw something
who the hell is over here Oh get off
he's in just waving my flashlight is
that something whoo oh man my finger
should not be worried about that nope
message hi mrs. Washington this is
sergeant Tate again it's bad news I'm
afraid we've been through the case file
and there's nothing we can do Nate's a
free man we don't have the legal power
to restrict his movement I know it's not
what you wanted to hear so call me if
you want to go for I know it's not what
you wanted to hear so call me to hear
much more about it in great detail so
did they actually like live in this
house up here and if they did why how'd
this kid go to school what's this over
here hello
hmm hello oh that's sad
Oh ready for the senior prom
so all these sure all these kids in high
school they don't seem like high
schoolers they seem like the high
schoolers that movie actors play when
they're like 28 and they try to be a
high schooler yeah I think I think he
said to go upstairs I do know that I
probably need to go upstairs but I'm
just checking everything because if
there's another solution that doesn't
involve burning people alive I'm gonna
try to find it who is stepping around is
that just me no that sounds like there's
more than me
alrighty then
whoo oh oh I'm going downstairs whoa oh
oh I see
whoo whoo
I mean this is very fancy very fancy
over here what the hell is going on here
cinema room damn it thing is locked up
tight all sad
okay
I guess that's got to be everything now
I gotta go upstairs I mean I haven't
seen anything that's like super bleah
obviously something that I could get to
burn the lockdown but I'm pretty sure
this is what I need and I'm I not am I
not gonna talk to anybody about getting
these premonitions some final
destination going on here all right
I mean if I could figure out how to get
the power on and maybe get the heat
going
lay it out help everything but I don't
think that's gonna be the case creepy
creepy creepy creepy whole bunch of
creepy creepy crawly creepy crawly hello
can I close that maybe no I'm just gonna
ignore it all right fine then we're on
our way thinking of more pickup lines
for Ashley weird strange pickup lines
good caught that face we're a hell am i
how big is this place
Oh
well Inferno for men really private
Easter god dammit I don't know how many
perfect yeah perfect
I don't know how he managed to grab that
dude we're freezing our buns off out
here it's exactly what he predicted he
premonition dit
yeah good don't look how about that did
I do good thank you thank you thank you
up I'll be here all week
crowd that thing freaked me out what was
it
are you okay it's like a bear or
something oh just a cute little baby
Wolverine baby don't worry buddy gonna
be a big boy soon a Wolverine in
wherever the hell they are in the
mountains
what where are they aren't Wolverines
like indigenous to Tanzania's not Ilana
no I don't know what it is oh my gosh
it's so good to be inside Univ it's
still kind of freezing in here yeah fire
go what's gonna looks any different
yeah nobody's been up here even with all
the police coming in and out hmm not a
lot of action up here lately oh oh
there's gonna be s actually hey never
mind
Joe make yourself at home bro will do
yeah come on in take a load off at
whatever you want you just take whatever
you want anyway right whoa easy there
cowboy
woo I saw um what the hell were you
doing with em out on the trail what I
saw you and em the telescope before we
just ran into each other been a while so
we hug and I said hello not against the
law
watch yourself Mike Washington right
right I'm sure it's all it was you know
what you can think whatever you want
it's a free country
watch yourself Mike
oh mm-hmm I don't like that Mike
guy that Mike guys not cool in my book I
am my god that is so gross
are you trying to swallow his face okay
seriously can she be any more obvious
no one wants in on your territory honey
excuse me did you say something oh did
you not hear me with your sluttiness to
our big congrats you're da cow that's
real deep calling miss homecoming a cow
hey that's I call for Jess hi I do
nothing but provoking everyone I'm
coming Jess jealous much yeah Jess
frigid for you too
hey that's that's uncalled whatever
extra don't give a crap what you think
at least I can think 4.0 on a roll
suck on that when you're trying to sleep
your way into a job who needs grades
when you've got all the natural
advantages you can handle oh you
couldn't buy a moldy loaf of bread with
your skanky ass are you serious do you
think that insole thing that is on
crack or something Frank J Mel Jess I
cause no no okay no you're the one who
needs to keep your nose out of other
people's business I'm about to get right
up in your business you oh you get
real cuz I am down to get real hmm stop
it
this is not why we came up here this is
not helping it's not what I wanted if we
can't get along for 10 minutes and maybe
we need a little bit of a break right
Mike why don't you check out the guest
cabin when I told you about yeah all
right
wanna go do that any place without that
yes right up the trail glad that's
over
hmm so Josh uh should we get this fire
going where's the hello should we my bag
the the little bag with the pink pattern
the one I got on Rodeo Mary are you
listening why don't you remember next to
the Italian shoe place where I got the
stilettos and you knocked over the rack
while you were drooling all over that
girl at the counter well I mean she was
asking about my letter chair right
because she gave a about your
designer letter jacket why do you hate
my jacket Matt I need my bag oh my god
m-maybe you just forgot it do you
seriously think I'd forget my bag whoa
are you guess not
oh come on
I think I know why Mike broke up with
her hell but I don't know why Mike went
with Jess okay ah these are not nice
people these are probably people that
won't last long in this game
why why why would you do that what no no
exiled exiled
how far is this cabin anyway way too far
is the coziest the most romantic love
den you will ever layer as if we ever
make it I have a feeling Lux on our side
okay buy your cards right and maybe you
will get lucky
hey porn stars gonna need these porn
star I paid to see you uh gross hey I'm
sorry to kick you out like that no
worries no oh I'm sure you'll find a way
to entertain yourselves mm-hmm
you have fun with the peanut gallery oh
I almost forgot
got to fire up the generator so you can
see where you're going
ARCA thanks Josh I Josh was flirting
with me okay well invite him up with us
wait really
what no oh so awkward ah I don't want
any of that ah okay so either way yeah
there we go I guess Jessie's
relationship with him is going down now
he's just gonna mumble into the camera
for a little bit I want to see what my
gym my decisions Wow
two more okay I'll check those out in
the next episode so thank you everybody
so much for watching thank you for
watching this video thank you for
watching the watching of the ones using
your eyes to look at it and here's to
listen damn it thank you everybody so
much for watching click the annotation
for music I've done in the past and as
always I will see you
and the next video